and now details on the sudden
announcement that has captured the
attention of the entire world hidden
among the countless billions of Wonka
bars are five gold tickets and to the
five people who find them will come the
most fabulous prize one could wish for a
lifetime supply of chocolate nobody
nobody ever comes out
[Music]
[Applause]
hidden among the countless billions of
water bars are five gold tickets a
lifetime supply of chocolate chocolate
I found some money in the street I
bought a Wonka bar to take over Saanich
ha look at a grandpa see for yourself
resent this ticket at the factory gates
at 10 o'clock in the morning of the
first day of October and do not be late
it's nice to have you here I'm so glad
you could come
this is going to be such an exciting day
I hope you enjoy it I think you will you
are now about to enter the nerve center
to the entire wonka factory inside this
room all of my dreams become realities
over there across the river Johnny
Devine save him he can't watch the plane
terrific pressure is building up behind
the blockage the suspense is terrible be
men you got a garbage strike going on
air Wanaka who wants an Everlasting
Gobstopper I can only give them to you
if you solemnly swear to keep them yeah
why don't you do anything stupid
if you may yo sue wow that you're
turning violet violet
[Music]
Oh
well well well - naughty nasty little
children gone
three children left these are the geese
that lay the golden eggs as you can see
they're larger than ordinary geese hey
daddy I want a golden goose here we go
again how much do you want for the
golden goose they're not for sale
name the price she can't have one he was
a bad egg now would you all please put
these on there's dangerous stuff inside
one provision my very latest and
greatest invention okay here it comes
there it is it's real taste it it's
delicious it's just got the smaller
that's all
[Music]
get away from that thing stop don't come
back
flying over our heads in a million
pieces
now watch the screen
how'd you parting is such sweet sorrow
they received in a swindler how could
you do a thing like this excuse me for
not showing you out straight up the
stairs you'll find the way I'm goodbye
to you both goodbye
let's take a break charlie nobody's
watching yeah a small one hurt us
mr. Bates
[Music]
I can't stop
I'm looking for a reason to subscribe
well how about action
subscribe for I saw someone dilation me
here and show it to me
look behind you or just subscribe to
join the party
don't miss out
[Music]